[Music]
back in action I was supposed to play
basketball 5:30 this morning Jim was
closed I would have been at the gym
Tyler you should kiss AJ in the face I
was you already up here weren't really
good month got a ton of family time hey
Wine Library it's Gary Vaynerchuk former
host of Wine Library TV and Sacha
Vaynerchuk a little trip to Boston
you know go get this talk but real quick
if you want to join the wine club swipe
up a quick little uh keynote in Germany
just get great talk felt really good
about it a little bit more of a senior
serious demeanor real fun got to take my
sister was on that trip with Raisa who's
trying to disappear I so don't be scared
there she has been with being her for
the last five or six years rice that's
six years alright she's gone um now
getting a quick haircut now that I got
my hair cut now now rejuvenated I think
one of the things that has separated me
in the business world my entire 20-year
career
sorry brand I'm kind of talking to
YouTube right now so stick with me but
this is for you too it's just [ __ ]
about the things that matter
everybody has 40 hours eighty hours in a
week depending on how you roll that's
why I'm so obsessed with new customers
that's why I'm so obsessed with nine
hundred every time I step away from a
situation whether at Wine Library Team
Gary at vaynermedia one of the things
that always spikes to the top of the
list prioritizing things that matter
things that impact your business buying
and selling and customer service is what
impacts Wine Library not just following
the process everybody so
process-oriented everybody's religious
to the process do the things that matter
do things that drive impact do the
things that actually will change your
business patience is equally tied into
things that matter a lot of times
because the things that matter are hard
so it takes time to I have time to sit
down with my employees I think those are
things that actually
okay hey man give you a gift it's
something that I got from the 2017 book
challenge yes
listen I wanted it to have just a second
for a New Jersey hustler real fast like
30 seconds one minute 57 seconds later
love it man take yourself stay well I'll
see you there
do I think actually you did Oh got it
people really all about them what are
you putting out content now Instagram
Facebook so it was really fun
YouTube I'm really trying to go deeper
for you in this new iteration I realize
ah document over create was such a
breakthrough for so many of you but
there is a middle
besides interviewing somebody Q&A is the
easiest way to create content instead of
creating it yourself yeah you know the
whole document versus create well maybe
you guys don't want to be reality TV
stars and document your whole day just
cuz documenting versus creating works
for so many of you you know my whole
thing is just start yeah and what holds
everybody back is creation which is why
documenting over create became such a
big thing and I think the thing that can
make you do is a Q&A format it's not on
you but you need to just pick phone
numbers and be like hey Karen from
Kansas City what's your question awesome
thank you so much good experience this
is the year to wear one Vaynerchuk
thanks man thank you so much cuz you
need success hit me up anytime Q&A is a
huge way to go
thank you brother what's up fellas
Michael Michael such a pleasure
mirthless such a pleasure cool I don't
have to worry about changing these at
all okay just a couple changes
throughout okay yep so gonna take some
photos here video for this Shopify thing
that I'm doing with my super excited
about it not even sure I'm allowed to
talk about it now beep where I said what
it is but excited about it
trying to get my modelling game
except back to Vayner yeah back to
[ __ ] super excited about this contest
I'm part of got a quick phone call right
now in probably two minutes late two
minutes late putting all the pieces
together my boy Russ [ __ ] fired up
I [ __ ] love his music you me is
probably hey Alexa can you play you me
by Russ hey Alexa come in with my Alexa
I can't find you me by Ross what the
[ __ ] Alexa thank you so much but you're
gonna be your this is like a official
but kind of like yeah you're still like
gonna be here right okay it's important
I'm gonna be there anyway might as well
get some show time so what is this bro
oh this is not the juice prep what is
this that's a protein shake do that was
such a big loss I'm stunned
I told you I've gained so much weight
but then last night like in one day of
fasting I lost the most weight pounds
yeah how is that all right yeah
good it's [ __ ] great okay good
[Music]
here at opponent events the student team
and clients get together I can't show
you guys find stuff I think it's a real
indication
by the scenes
800 was happening you know get the
client's media company like a lot of
[ __ ] but some glad we to show you that's
today's special cottagey bounce-back
episode I always fun guys watch what I'm
doing
not what I'm saying if I'm posting a lot
of interim that focused on my podcast
matters if I'm DMing that scale matters
this is a nice way to narrate what I've
been trying to get you to do all along
we just watch me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]